[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us this week at the
round table of dim lighting we have
invited mythical crew member Kevin to
come in here and we are going to have an
intriguing conversation about the
world's longest-running treasure hunt on
a haunted island the haunted part
question mark it's it's it's a fun a
very mysterious it's at least mysterious
incredibly intriguing conversation with
Kevin about something very mythical I
mean the reason that we're doing this we
actually asked Kevin to find something
that he knew just based on his history
with us and the kinds of things that we
find interesting to find something
mythical for us to talk about yeah
because I think that that's one of the
things that ear biscuits is becoming is
a podcast where we explore mythicality
now in mythical we don't mean like fake
or legendary don't know that you know it
will be stall ready but but actually in
in writing the book of mythicality right
we really started to understand what
mythicality meant what it means to be
mythical creativity curiosity and
tomfoolery being the tenants of yeah
Akala tea so we kind of hone in on the
curiosity aspect of mythicality tonight
with Kevin yes so while we're talking
about the book we would let you know it
is available for pre-order right now net
to a book of mythicality calm and I
think we've communicated this a number
of times as we've talked about the book
but but maybe we haven't communicated it
quite as fully as we could have cuz I
think a lot of people are like I don't
know what this boots gonna be I trusted
it's gonna be good if you guys are
excited about it but I think whatever
you think it's gonna be it's in there
because everything that we could think
of like personal stories we
illustrations the intriguing tale report
it's all a lot of ourselves in there so
I think it is one part memoir so you get
a lot of this that the things that we've
shared growing up together and working
together for years that we think have
brought mythicality to our lives but
there's also just all kinds of things
that we find mythical in the world in
history and it's kind of tied into 20
different aspects of mythicality and
kind of how we interact with those in
our own lives and then how we've seen
other people embody those things it's it
was a blast to put together there is a
whole chapter related to something akin
to buried treasure
yeah I'm not gonna don't go no way to
give away too much right now about
burying something yeah but and how you
can get involved in but I think the
point is is that by writing the book I
think it brought more definition to what
it is that we've been trying to do with
all the work that we've done over the
past decade together and even that even
before that and it's also brought
definition to what we want to do when we
have a conversation on air biscuits the
kind of things that we want to explore
so it all kinds of kind of works
together so if you're a mythical beast
if you've been a mythical beast for any
amount of time or if you're just finding
this for the first time we think I mean
we wrote the book so that you would
enjoy it but we we are very confident
that you're gonna enjoy it
so welcome ethicality calm in unison
listen you don't have to type in unison
you can though I was just cut right out
of the rocks I give you an error an HTTP
error
you got a slash in unison it might it'll
still take you to the right place
different website I don't know so we're
gonna talk to Kevin Tapani that
curiosity that we all enjoy but first I
should give you an update up and I want
to give you an update on my daughter
Lily's major back surgery now that it's
over I think I want to thank all of you
for your for your support for your
prayers for your just your consideration
a lot of people you sent sent gifts and
and cards of encouragement
to her in it and it's it it was all very
touching and it really helped so the the
great news is that the surgery went
exactly it how we hoped I mean it went
off without a hitch
her she had severe scoliosis which was
her her back was curved sideways like an
S I mean looking at the x-rays I mean I
talked about this on the other ear
biscuits so you can go back and listen
to that but it it definitely floored us
back in January so a lot of this year
has been leading up to the surgery which
as of the recording this episode was one
week ago one week ago right now we're
moving into like her hospital room and
for where she would spend the next five
days now she's at home recovering she's
doing great
it's amazing how she can she can roll
over in bed roll out of bed walk around
walk down our street take pictures of
flowers taking pictures that's what she
likes to do I didn't think the doctor
was taking pictures has very little to
do with the the fusion of your spine
right which was fused from l4 to Elysee
LS it sells at the bottom Elle's at the
bottom T's at the top t4 to l3 which is
the vast majority of her back yeah I
mean she's and she's got a scar that
that she's very proud of and we all are
that goes the majority of her back this
healing up great but the fact that they
went in there and they put two metal
rods that they custom bent they like
they like smooshed her spine to be back
no longer than s they a custom bent rods
don't even understand delighted that too
so she could have proper posture and
then they attach those rods using
titanium screws huge screws into her
vertebrae you know how many anymore six
weeks after that she's like fully
recovered you know how many
people they had to go through before
they got to the point where they do it
this way
Oh No yeah thing about the first guy oh
my goodness yeah I mean it wasn't just
opened up the back and they were like oh
maybe we'll push you pull this way off I
was here and then he died
I mean seriously well yeah I mean
someone who's like a last resort type of
thing yeah well actually my kids are
asking what happened I think as well for
for the vast majority of his vast
majority of history you just lived with
it maybe we could maybe we could get a
doctor in here to talk about that maybe
Lilly's doctor will come in here dr.
Tolo he was amazing
but but seriously though for like yeah
99.99% of human history what human
history's 200,000 or more and there's
plenty of people who you're saying who
lived with it and that was it I'm saying
absolutely the vast majority of people
who have ever lived just lived with it
and whatever and wherever it ends up
because it increases over time I know
that's one of the reasons that you got
to correct it right but then you just
think okay you're born in 1950 and then
they've got some sort of thing that they
do but you or do you tell me that just
because one years ago progress you can't
I mean it collected like smooches your
organ disease the way that you you die
but like you were saying that like 20
years ago you'd be in a cast like a
full-body cast or maybe I don't know 30
years ago whatever for like six months
yeah and now they figured out that oh if
we get them moving right after and
they've got all these amazing medicines
that they can give you pain relievers
and stuff so that you're able to get up
and walk I mean the first night let me
tell you let me tell you a little bit
about the surgery and then I'll get I'll
get back to that point in terms of her
recovery but I just wanted to share the
experience with you guys I mean we got
up at like 4:00 a.m. to get to I was
about to say the airport we didn't have
to fly anywhere right - guys it feels
like an airport to get to the hospital
by like five you know it wasn't until
7:45 that she went into surgery so
there's like all this all this prep and
checking in and taking blood again and
all this stuff it's so nerve-wracking to
know that you know okay this is it this
is the
we've been waiting for all year and this
is about to happen I think she was most
concerned about getting the happy juice
is what they called it which kind of
relaxes you in the pre-op place before
they give you an IV they offer you some
well Christy asked for some because she
was she was she was pretty anxious at
the moment but they didn't do that don't
get they did not they did not give her
or me any of the happy to have that in
the hotel the hospital bar but she I
think Lily was just concerned about
what's it gonna feel like cuz she was
told that she wouldn't remember stuff at
a certain point so what's it feel like
to stop being able to remember any
nothing and no it doesn't feel like
anything at all you don't remember and
so then they gave her the IV and then
they said we're gonna wheel you into
surgery and mom and dad you can walk
with us til we get to the I mean we came
to these doors that were in my memory
they were orange like so I guess they
were aren't you I didn't take that happy
juice I think I remember in my memory
they were what they were they were
alarmingly colored doors that we were
not allowed to go that's whether orange
and then then the nurses who were
wheeling her and said okay this is this
is this is where you have the hugs and
kisses because I didn't they don't want
to say this is where you say goodbye
because that would be really morbid and
and tap right into our fears that we
were saying goodbye right cuz there's
what like a 1 in 1,000 I don't know so
small a small chance it happens to
somebody people go under for general
anesthesia and they don't wake up well
there's in there's risk of paralysis and
you know yeah or death I mean I had to
sign a form that spelled out literally
pointed all these things out like these
are the is very very unlikely but you
know she could die she could be
paralyzed you know it's like frickin
scary we didn't do it right before them
we did it
months before that moment they don't
want they don't put too much on you at
once yeah I didn't want to but but even
in that moment that that was a very
difficult moment when we were saying you
know kissing her and hugging her and
saying alright we'll be waiting and that
because you don't know when the toughest
points going to be because you knew the
surgery was gonna last a long time but I
I'll say after the fact that was
probably that was definitely in the top
three maybe the worst point when it's
like you know okay you're actually
saying I'll see you on the other side of
this surgery so that was pretty
difficult but then they whisk her away
and they whisk us into an elevator and
down into the the waiting room and they
give you a pager so you can walk around
kind of like at a restaurant type pager
but then they have screens up there that
have her number they don't have her name
so no one else oh no we're right this
person is so she had her number and like
he was constantly looking up there
waiting and you know it was six and a
half hours of waiting yeah that's great
I mean the surgery was actually we come
to find out later they started the
surgery late so the actual surgery was
five hours but we were out there waiting
and all that the board told us was she
was in she was in the operating room and
or pre-op which she had already passed
that she was in the operating room
according to that screen for six and a
half hours and then it they moved her to
recovery and that's when we could go see
her and they came out every three hours
and said everything's going okay but
every time they come out you're like
really I mean look at what are they
gonna say yeah it's like that moment
when somebody comes and there was just a
receptionist that they would call and
the receptionist would relay it and I
thought if something was really going
wrong someone else would come out so I
took I found ways to take comfort in
like my interpretation of how they would
do things and they if they were going
wrong that were different than how they
actually told me but that's six and a
half hours I mean because I mean you
were there we had other friends there
anyway it was extremely helpful to you
know past the time like Christy have
friends who brought like a cheese plate
and you know it's like cheese plate had
the semblance of a party charcuterie we
were like we were like offering some
charcuterie to other people there who
cuz they I mean other people's kids are
in there too there was an everybody knew
it was another number who was a who's
waiting for seven hours it's not like we
were the only people going through
something this scary
and then the docket we finally met with
a doctor and he said everything went
great they straightened her out he said
we actually went too far and then had to
come back a little bit I'm like
overcorrection
well it's it's it there's there's an art
to it apparently you know you're you're
you're been in these rods manually you
got a freaking blacksmith in there thank
ya thank very high it may be horses in
there too I don't know I doubt it
there's a reason they don't let me in
there you know I don't you would have to
see them I don't want to see the
blacksmith they bump anybody the risk of
you getting injured by being in the
operating room was significantly higher
than the wrist of Lily what you mention
an IV or blood I'm probably gonna faint
right you know like Lily was laughing at
me half the time when they were to every
time they talk about the IV or the
doctor said everything went great and
then we go back there I mean she's in
like her face is all swollen her lips
are swollen looked like she had had like
some sort of plastic surgery
like well maybe they threw a baby you
gave her a lip enlargement for free are
you gonna charge me for that highly
packaged but it was um cuz she's face
down for five hours while they're doing
this surgery but was it in facedown on
like a massage doughnut or something
they didn't let me in I don't know I
didn't ask that question but it had to
be something that was on something it
wasn't like just put her face down in a
pillow
yeah they went in suffocate her yeah I
mentioned that it was like a massage
table though just being in the same
position for six hours without moving
alone is enough to and she was very
groggy she said before he went back
there her her legs were moving around so
much which is a great sign well I'd say
so yeah but they were moving so much
they had to sedate or more because she
was moving around too much because she
was disoriented by the time we saw her
she was like more sedated and it took
her you know an hour before we were able
to have a conversation and you know we
told her your back straight and she
started crying and and you know the
anesthesia will make you it can make you
really emotional and I was like are you
okay she was like I'm just so happy and
it was it was great you know that like
that was her first reaction was like
tears of joy that like it worked and we
so then we that by that might they moved
her into the hospital bed they as a
practice they make you sit up the first
night she sat up vomited what she was
able to drink cuz he was on clear
liquids she was so weak the next morning
they got her to stand up and take a few
steps which was extremely dramatic I saw
that video Chris I I wasn't there for
that because I missed your daughter's
first steps I was with the boys because
it was important you know excuses we
both couldn't stay there the first night
I stayed with the boys you know be a
support structure for them and then I
got there as soon as I could after
getting them off to school and then so I
missed that but if I was there I
probably would've gotten vomited all
over because she took two steps it
vomited again and then she had to get
two units of blood over that day to get
some sort of strength because of what
she lost her in the surgery but then
that she really turned a corner after
that sitting in the next day she was up
walking she had to do like a she had to
demonstrate she could walk upstairs
before she could come home it's
miraculous what I mean we talked to a
woman from back in North Carolina who
was friend of ours who's 50 years old
who went through the same surgery and
she said it took her a year to recover
oh it's gonna take Lily six weeks to
recover the other ages I mean
significant I'm like can you feel these
these titanium bars in your back she's
like no I kind of feel like she kind of
has she kind of turned like Batman she
can turn her neck but she's not used to
the way her muscles
well the way are backwards she's got a
but she doesn't feel the you and you got
to heal completely before you're willing
to start moving or moving it around but
she doesn't feel like the bars and I'm
not like poking on her back or anything
I wouldn't suggest doing that for a
while yeah but she she made it I mean I
think the final you know a big milestone
was when we got in the van leaving the
hospital to come home and we get in you
know she gets in the front seat with all
her pillow
Krissi's in the backseat and I'm in the
driver seat and I just had a flashback
to the moment to the day we found out
that she was gonna have to have surgery
like the first diagnosis the story I
told where we got back in the minivan
and all three of us just cried and I
feel like it came full circle when we
got in the minivan again leaving the
hospital for the first time and we all
looked at each other and Lily was like
we did it so you know the first time in
the minivan it was like we need to do
this I need this surgery that was that
was her take immediately we had to be
convinced it was the right thing to do
and then it was at the end it was like
we did it
it's like you know so I'll never I'll
never forget that moment when we could
breathe a sigh of relief and know that
okay it was successful and I mean
there's there's weeks of recovery ahead
of us but I'm so grateful to of course
all the doctors and nurses and I can do
the Jimmy Kimmel thing but I'm not going
to where he mentioned all the doctors
and nurses and well you can mention the
Children's Hospital Children's Hospital
la yeah yeah donate to them get on the
Jimmy Kimmel wagon do that I've done it
you should do it too yeah but they do
amazing work there and yeah it's I mean
it's it's not over but for the most part
it's over so I wanted to give you the
update and that's it well we're glad
that you're Bionic daughter is yeah
she's part Wolverine well on her way
vampire getting other well on way to a
hundred percent yeah man
and now let's let's let's shift gears
and get to something more more
intriguing and not related to the
heaviness of back surgery now that
that's behind us bring Kevin in here but
first we're gonna take a short break to
let you know about these not butter
flavored but Buttered looking your
biscuits mason jars now available at
Wrigley not calm slash store I'm saying
they do they look like jars coated in
biscuit batter but that with a
three-dimensional ear
get logo on the front but it's not
biscuit batter it's just a jar you can
put anything in its surrounding biscuit
batter it holds liquids we are currently
have liquids in here the liquid that I'm
drinking today is water also air
biscuits is brought to you by water they
would do things like that on Sesame
Street remember that because they don't
have sponsors because it was because it
was like public yeah
brought to you by water but that ain't
us brother
this ain't public water I mean we
haven't gone public yet when we do who
those crazy laughing get yours that
rattling calm / store yes now on to the
biscuit so Kevin did you have to travel
for this are you coming back from a
journey only from my desk to here you
traverse the Internet
yes I like to pretend that we sent you
out we don't have that kind of budget
man but if this goes well maybe we will
yeah we could maybe we'll Commission and
like put you up him forth like you wear
all khaki I mean I did watch a lot of
History Channel what usually makes me
feel like I'm going to a place oh yeah
so in some way I did do you like khaki
I've never seen you in much khaki I
don't like it like Stevie has that khaki
onesie this she wears and she has like a
stranger the only person I know besides
cartoon characters khaki onesies but hey
listen but we got to say if we start
sending you out like you know go forth
son I definitely think you should wear
khaki onesie and it should be like a
sponsorship I mean a maker of us both
male rappers if you're a mate I mean
khaki onesie and that's a and that
you're willing to de-spawn sir a trip is
a Robin let us know you've seen them
Robin I'll drop him for him yeah I see
him I think is a treasure hunter khaki
shorts would be a given yes I feel like
I'd have to pants you might have to wear
a mount to make me both other treasure
hunters I think that you're wearing two
different things
yes you don't want other treasure
hunters didn't know that you have a
wrapper on so you gotta wear a belt to
separate I could do that so
is the world's longest-running treasure
hunt this is the world's longest-running
treasure hunt yes in history and you're
in your part of it now I am part of it
yeah and are you gonna suck at him I am
I'm not an expert by any means we don't
need to know but I am well say that I am
an ex you are all me that's better it's
better I believe you feel wearing a
khaki Rompin but it sounds like a
command rob him now I don't want to ask
the follow-up question of what that
means so instead I'll ask where do we
start set the stage I'm gonna I'm gonna
tease you guys first oh yeah I have a
teaser for this but also I just got to
say you know I did ear biscuits on the
other end yeah they're a year yeah and
we hi we hired Kevin yeah to produce ear
biscuit yeah was your first job with us
yep and then like between the
researching of people and then we
started branching out doing other stuff
we saw like a burgeoning potential movie
over to good mythical morning when when
every bus gets slowed down and it was
great and I'd never this is the first
time I've have a guest perspective
coming in yeah and I've done this so
many times and I got nervous coming and
you know what it is it's the dim
lighting yeah the day buddy mm I feel
like you're being lulled into something
are you gonna be taking advantage you do
I used to set the dim lighting yeah
that's why you should have your romper
on we can romp you start you started
teasing us you better be wearing that
right you do you know you don't get
around let's move on you're doing the
wrong thing I'm doing the robbing I'm
gonna romp and tease right now so this
longest-running treasure head yeah I'm
gonna tell you what it involves it
involves a deep hit on a small island a
small haunted island Oh Oh
booby traps pirates and conquistadors
mm-hmm
it involves a pack of crazed dogs with
fiery eyes what motorcycle Daredevils
Kevin a crow no you didn't you didn't
bring the crow in this did you they're
smart they are smart he's not making it
up
a u.s. president has a press okay I'll
tell you which one later John Wayne and
quite possibly but not actually the Holy
Grail you but you you spoiled that one
side a little bit but not probably
probably not but but maybe we both need
the possibility open yes the best way to
do this is from the beginning okay so
we're gonna start from 1795 okay all
right put yourself there there's a
island called Oak Island it's off the
coast of Nova Scotia Canada and the
Atlantic Ocean there's one off in North
Carolina too but this is not that one it
looks like no it looks like the shape of
a peanut sort of now in 1795 now this
has a lot of history to it pirates and
they say it's haunted the first settlers
of the island believed it was haunted
there was always strange lights emitting
from the island there's a story about
two fishermen in the 1800s that went
exploring and they were never seen again
in 1795 a teenager named Daniel McGinnis
saw some lights coming off the island so
he grabbed two of his buddies and they
went out there exploring those two guys
were John Smith and Anthony Vaughn what
they discovered was this myth
John's mooring maybe Anthony Vaughn's
okay though as white in teased and a guy
named John Smith but Daniel McGinnis and
these two guys saw this circular
depression in the ground and they
thought something's under there so they
started digging okay and they get well
they had to go get shovels and whatnot
but they started digging mhm and they
got ten feet down and after 10 feet they
hit a floor of oak logs now Oak Island
was called Oak Island because it used to
be filled with oak trees okay so maybe
not that in common that they see a floor
there but they dig ten feet down more to
20 feet these guys are digging like
crazy they're diggin I said these
shovels with shovels they broke through
they broke through the woodland oak
floor yeah like wood oak floor logs get
through that 20 feet there's another
floor what they break through that
they go down to 30 feet another wood
floor this time they're a little bit
tired there are 30 feet down they're a
little like you would have any idea how
long this took it sounds like yeah days
yeah took a little while week they're
camping there for a while they were 30
feet down and they were in over their
heads Kevin yeah well they were already
there at 10 feet I heard that on the
History Channel that wasn't me credit
all credit to you channel you will be a
great dad one day I know I'm practicing
so here's what they do they decide we're
in over our heads we need to get some
help they do but it takes them eight
years did they did they hide the hole or
I you know that's unclear they must have
because nobody else stumbled on it I
mean it is a little island in the middle
of nowhere
essentially all right so right there's a
lot of demand for this it seems like
that you can make this up but then did
they prove this part of it they did so
what they did was eight years later they
came back equipped with the Onslow
company hmm
so the Onslow company was just a company
that believed them and they had a crew
and they had some money and some
equipment so they came out they started
digging they got past that 30 mark they
got to 40 feet guess what was their logs
logs but there was also a layer of
charcoal that was found what kind of
weird right kind of weird charcoal and
logs somebody camping down there let's
go to 50 feet cooking cooking I mean
that you you you bury charcoal when
you're like cooking a pig the Hawaiians
you think somebody's been cooking a pig
not dignity 40 feet deep what okay but
if you're on and I I mean if you're on
an island you go 40 feet deep right
aren't you hitting water table at some
point Oh we'll get there okay yeah yeah
50 feet deep another layer logs and this
time some putty on top oh definitely a
barbecue at this point some putty how
what's the diameter of this hole when
you're going 50 feet deep this is like a
huge hole it's like a crazy it's a big
it's I have a it's a big circle well you
can dig I mean when you dig a well you
don't have to keep maintaining this slow
when you dig if your buttressing it
properly we have a civil engineering
degree yeah I took a whole class on hole
digging sounds buttressing is very
important
maybe they buttress down to 60 feet and
down there this is where it gets a
little strange another floor and there
was some coconut fiber down there now
there isn't a coconut tree for 1,500
miles coconut fiber yes coconut fiber so
coconut fiber do a little research
coconut fiber back in the day was used
on ships pirate ships mm-hmm as
something that they would line valuables
with to protect it so like they'd have a
chest they'd shove a bunch of coconut
fiber in there and then put the valuable
in there and close it up like packing
peanuts like packing peanuts exactly
pirate packing peanuts at this point I
would think that I was digging through a
ship that gotten buried sideways
yeah like oak boards every 10 feet like
a ship that somehow got on its end and
you were like digging through rooms so
they're hoping that's what it is right
but they're open at this point they're
gonna strike treasure I mean that's why
that's why this company comes out there
yes even before they're hidden coconut
husks right there's a company involved
because they want some money that's
right but there was not really
indication that it's just a it's just a
mysterious haul wishful thinking wishful
thinking I mean let me ask one question
yes without spoiling anything about
where where this is going and I want you
to tell me think about where this is
going but this aspect of it seems so
crazy right
this aspect of it has been verified by
modern-day people oh yeah yep everything
you've told us it's true
this isn't like these guys could just be
making this up but it's like I mean this
isn't that long ago I guess that at 20
feet by the way now you're asking at 60
feet yeah I mean well yeah ready to 20
feet yeah okay there's a lot of
variables but yeah a lot of testing a
lot of professors involved in this
scientists professors good if the
professor's is good fencers want to cut
it that money to man the gold coins they
don't get paid extra though they have to
give it to the school if you find
something as a professor I think you
have put it a little
so there's 60 feet at this point sixty
feet we're gonna skip down now to 90
feet it gets more interesting in 90 feet
cuz at 90 feet they find the first real
clue it's a cement slab I'm gonna it's
actually not cement it's a stone slab
looks like a headstone maybe you can
kind of describe that for the audio
listeners here and see if you can
translate it well there's two lines of I
don't like symbols that are like
triangles circles with lines through
them an arrow star arrow triangle colons
percent signs crosses ones that one of
those is Theta I would say this is
dingbats hmm yeah yeah yeah web ding
font yeah and so this is obviously
somebody was on the internet or somebody
this is the beginning of word yeah
basic Microsoft Word a professor
translated this or at least there's a
theory to his translation here okay and
what he believes this reads is forty
feet below two million pounds are buried
yeah that's yeah you can see like you
see it already no I'm saying that like
now that you said that forty yeah see
the triangle and the triangle feet this
is the debt triangle and that triangle
yeah yeah I don't see it but how many
pounds two million pounds 40 feet below
and link that's that's money in England
yeah and a lot of it about like two two
million pounds of like their fat that
sum or log I liposuction many people do
you mean pounds of logs now side no you
don't stop now especially when they find
this and here's a little side note about
this John Smith one of the three John
Smith dudes that went down there he took
this home and apparently put it in his
fireplace I don't know why as a
decoration or something I'm not sure so
this is a replica yeah I was gonna say
yeah well it it does look it almost
looks like somebody just fishy
it why it's white out yeah drew on a
drew on a slab so it definitely seems
replica ish fishies good though but
let's keep going
so now they're at about the hundred and
hundred hundred and ten foot area so
what this company does is they take this
iron rod to start probing down lower and
they hit another kind of wood mm-hmm
so they're still hitting things it was
too dark at this point but what they
thought was they might have struck the
treasure box but it was dark so they
couldn't go down kind of a cliffhanger
they all have to go home at night
they're very excited they come home and
I come home they come back the next day
and this is where the drama kicks in
nothing's there no it is there now this
pit is filled with water
what so remember I told you earlier
there are some booby traps involved up
in this thing mmm here comes the booby
traps now they didn't piece this all
together until years later but I'm gonna
tell you how these booby traps went who
ever constructed this they built a
tunnel system underground what they did
was they built that they found out what
you're telling me now was proven later
was proven later yeah so we have total
at this point of the story this we know
that it was a booby trap yes and they
piped in water that would fill up the
place when you reach a certain death yes
because what they did was when they
prodded with that rod they unlatched a
basically like a hydraulic door system
that was built under there that opened
up and water funneled into this thing so
when these guys had ID at 110 feet 110
feet hundred and 110 feet down these
guys didn't know what it was so they
were using buckets and things trying to
empty it but it kept filling so what
they found out later was that whoever
constructed this made these five by the
coast they built a dam and they had
these five separate tunnels that all
came together into one and that one
tunnel went down to the hundred and ten
hundred one hundred and ten mark feet
down in this money pit and it connected
there so that if you struck it you'd
open it up and would fill with water and
you couldn't go back down and again
that that okay if they wouldn't have
gone home for the night somebody
probably would have drowned but all this
stuff was built before 1795 and the idea
of someone being able to drill a hole
from the beach - you know laterally to
make this place the technology that
would be required to do that just so you
can bury a treasure
probably alien could be there's theories
we'll get to them aliens have the
technology okay I was pulled off yeah
there's a lot of theories I'll tell you
some of them later you can see which
ones you like they couldn't figure out
what to do they tried a lot of different
things couldn't figure out Ranna
figure it out ran out of money but so at
that time they did not know that this is
not was happening no because they could
have gone they could have gone to the
other end and plugged it up and right
with solve their problems yeah didn't
know had no idea they tried everything
they could empty it that in work they
even tried drilling down another hole
next to it and that ended up filling
with water this is like a baby Jessica
situation wasn't she the one that got
caught in the well yeah and they do and
they did the hole next to it they did
the hole next to the hole yeah yeah
pulled been the same thing happened
their Colombian guy still feeding her
she's out she's out now
she got out I remember I saw it on the
television I had cried I cried you had
cried I cried but when baby Jessica came
out you didn't cry huh I wasn't into it
it's like all right it's over what I
wasn't following it I'm not in there
like soap operas well it's real I don't
know anything about it but I do know
that I don't even know I can tell you
that they ran out of money and they
abandoned their search and 45 years went
by with no other searches so this thing
sat filled with water for 45 years until
18-49 when the Truro company came in
mm-hmm this is the next company to come
in and start digging around
they used now there's a little math here
so what they did was they dropped a oh I
think they called it a pod augur pod
augur let's call it that yeah we'll call
it a pod augur so so four years how many
years 4045 years they were
I just imagine everybody was talking
about this thing and it went from like
hearsay to myth the legend and the
implication is whoever whoever gets down
in there and finds the treasure gets it
yeah but it's Canada I mean there's not
it's weird we're not talking about a lot
of people they don't get excited about
much either mmm I mean I think if this
was like you know in Mississippi they'd
all be really excited about it but this
is Nova Scotia yeah they got better
things to do like yeah chill out and be
nice they already know that like money
is not the the key to happiness anyway
they're like there's a lot of trouble to
get down there and then what are you
getting you get two million pounds who
cares
hey hey you know so I don't think I
think you may be misunderstanding that
amount of drama but it is still cool
it's cool yeah but another company's
dropping pods another company's dropping
pods and here's what they discovered
they got back down to the same mark with
a with a pod and they went through 12
inches and hit I'm sorry they went
through four inches of oak when they got
down to the same point and then they hit
and this is in the water past that
tunnel okay they didn't empty the the
thing somebody operating this thing yes
it was a cement it's a submarine vessel
I send you air yeah like that so then
there was a guy down there he's a blood
he's in a pod with an auger Oh hot auger
yes awesome so then they got through six
inches of spruce and down to the hundred
and twelve feet it was a wood lover's
dream yeah your dream yeah it was only
clay and then after that they retrieved
now here's they're collecting things now
they got two pieces of gold metal links
like links on a chain mm-hmm that comes
up and are we at the forty feet below
the like we're further now so they're
protected before where they said that
the clue said the two million they got
them because they actually got down to a
hundred they thought between 154 and 161
foot level there was a vault that's what
they thought it was it was like a vault
of wooden boxes and they actually even
penetrated through that and below that
was an iron plate that was impenetrable
they couldn't get through it at least at
that time but they thought that they had
hit the treasure there so they what
happened after that was they came up
empty-handed they tried they kept trying
to plug the tunnel like you said earlier
and they couldn't quite get it right
they couldn't they couldn't get all I
think they found one of the five
compartments and plugged it but they
couldn't figure out the whole system
mm-hmm and they couldn't get it fully
plugged so they also ran out of money
yeah and the search ended there so they
retrieved a few things got a little
further everybody gets a little bit
further as they pull at gold links yeah
a couple of gold links and you know
there's a lot of little things that came
up throughout this tunnel I may forget
some of them just trying to bring up the
important ones that stuck with me so now
we're gonna cover the next hundred years
we're coming pretty close future what
stuck with you exactly that's all we
want okay so now we're gonna cover 1861
to 1965 so we're going like the next
hundred years we're getting real close
to current day yeah okay we are a bunch
of companies involved the random times
Oak Island Association Oak Island
treasure company meanwhile they're
people how inhabited is this island by
you know the mid 1800 not very and that
was something I was going to talk about
a little later but basically the later
and closer and time it got to now the
more trouble there was with ownership of
the land because people wanted to own
land to own the treasure okay so there's
a lot of trouble with that okay but at
this point there was a company that
started for the sole purpose of finding
this stuff because they call themselves
the Oak Island treasure
exactly yeah Oak Island treasure company
okay I'm gonna call ourselves well what
do we do how do we do it why do we do it
got it so I'm gonna tell you some of
their discoveries in this hundred year
span and then we're gonna get to the
deaths because that's very important
yeah nobody's died yet no but they will
in 1897 when's the crow come into this
well the crow the crow is kind of a side
note but you'll like the crow don't
forget the car I won't forget to crush
you tease the crow so they found in 1897
a stone
triangle it was off the coast that
pointed directly towards the tunnel just
another compromise rates pirates man
they're always finding these little
things that kept them going you know
like there's nothing there but then
they'd see a triangle that points to the
hole and they thought there's something
there they also found a piece of
sheepskin parchment I want to show you
guys this - the sheepskin parchment had
the letters V and I on it
the bi-curious not IV nope nope that's
that's the Roman numeral six they also
via got to the point with technology
with cameras they found this down in
there yeah a partner down in there
parchment with a letter VI on it that
comes into play and a theory later I'll
tell you about so they lowered a camera
down they thought they found other
things too like a human hand some tools
we define a human Hannah you don't be a
problem could be a prop could be a
worker from the past you know it's hard
to pinpoint where these things are
coming from a lot of hands a lot of
people but in that time people died okay
this is important because the first two
people that died were in the mid-1800s
one of them a steam steam boiler blew up
I thought you guys I want um Steamboat
Willie come here I don't know what his
name was but boiler blew up Steamboat
Willie got blowed up by a steam boiler
another guy fell down a shaft now I
don't know what shaft they just said he
fell in a shaft I imagine it's the shaft
or shaft next to it the you dug yeah but
he found out now I want to introduce you
to the rest all family
Robert rest all on his wife Mildred now
these were the motorcycle Daredevils
that was their jobs bye-bye trade that's
what they did for a living when they
heard about this motorcycle daredevil
notice that Evel Knievel Keeney all day
but on the mainland on the mainland
husband-and-wife no Canadian though I
believe so yeah although you know I'm
not the expert here but I am the expert
okay so you're our X I'm your expert so
they wanted a piece of the action they
thought we're Daredevils we'll get in on
this game mm-hmm they move their family
out frequent rationalisation things
amongst
motorcyclists yeah especially when
you're a daredevil they move their
family out there they're out there
for six years working on this and
there's like you can see videos of them
talking about how they're gonna get to
it they're gonna get the sorta like the
60s at this point yeah this point is
1959 to 1965 bingo
so unfortunately it didn't pan out that
way for Robert in 1965 he was working on
one of the pits and he breathed in some
type of poisonous gas and he fell he
died and his his son ran after him to
help him he breathing the gas and died
he died two other workers ran after them
breathed in the gas and they know this
was just something from the excavation
that not sure what the gas or the curse
or the curse this point they have to be
saying there's a curse yes
the moral of the story is don't go in
and try to save your dad that's right
not unless he's unless he's a motorcycle
daredevil which he was and that in which
case you're right don't save your dad
hold your breath yeah so okay now
remember about six people have died just
got to remember that okay it's a very
important thing remember that six people
died yeah
VI VI six people died I'm gonna come
back to the six people died Roman
numerals now I mentioned a couple of
famous people got involved no you didn't
yes you did remember the president the
United States you want to know which one
it was at that time it wells earlier it
was in 1909 it was Franklin Roosevelt
okay so he he was all excited by this so
he bought into some stock for one of the
treasure searching companies I don't
know if it was the one or a different
one and he actually went out there twice
to be part of the excavation there's a
picture of FDR FDR yeah trip on that huh
and there were a new new deal and then
John Wayne went out there looking for a
new deal and it's right up his alley
yeah well I could go up there and find
me some treasure yeah John Wayne is uh
from sidenote he went to school in my
hometown of Lancaster California really
yeah you met any of his relatives
none of them not one apparently he used
to talk highly of it which is weird cuz
I never do
so also I just dropped out me James
Lawson I just lost my audio oh yeah I
like laugh so loud we lost it it was
like a shot to my system disorder I was
back there okay Meg easy and
everything's good
got I thought the curse had hit up yeah
had like hold your breath like when I
was watching the ring that time and
right at the moment where she was about
to come out of the TV the whole
entertainment system went down well and
I rent me and my father-in-law ran
across the house to be with my
mother-in-law
we're not again today we're not again
dude it's happening it's it's the curse
jiggles are you seeing anything over
there Megan when that happens jiggle
wires or is it just us on this side it's
that thing it's the short on the thing
oh my gosh I'm kind of getting freaked
out I don't think well one of these
people one of us dies I'm not sticking
around I'm believing not gonna make the
same mistake well unless you're the one
who dies if you if one of us dies then
the rest of us need to go - Oh Kyle is
it coming back no nothing I think these
six people are here guys checky checky
checky checked here it comes again free
nope free there is a teeny little
difference mean that yeah and this
there's no in there and then I cut this
on and you get a teeny bit yeah you want
if if you're 100 percent sure that we're
good that you're still reading we'll
just take these off keep going yeah I
think it's I think it's this baby yeah
probably the Curt the Oak Island curse
has hit our I don't think you can cross
the border I don't think in cross of
work unless it's through a podcast
perhaps it can just through the internet
man maybe the aliens who are the ones
who set this up they don't like you when
you start talking about this and have a
way appear you have a way of controlling
our technology any sort of resistance in
while researching this I'm smooth
sailing I got real tired last night
working on this long wearing you down
yeah why are we down a little bit the
thing is is the Oak Island money pit no
money has come out of it all
money's gone into it right that's why
it's the money pit uh so what happened
to the six where okay so here we are
we're not we're not gonna take bad
headphones for an answer
curse ghosts no we won't press it on
there is a lot of people do believe in a
curse including the History Channel and
that's that's gonna be coming up here on
the close but these six people died keep
that in mind told you about Roosevelt
and John Wayne so this brings us up to
pretty much current time I told you
there was some battle for the land they
realized not long ago that the only real
way to make money off of this island was
tourism yes exactly and then it became a
battle of who owned the land to collect
in on that tourism so in 2006 two
brothers essentially took hold of the
entire island
these dudes names were there listening
to this right now they probably are
listening to this live yeah they're the
ones that think of this high months I'm
so on edge like I'm freaked out and when
you're like they're listening I thought
you're talking to ghosts well but I mean
I I don't mean to tempt fate or anything
but all they did is take our headphones
out I mean we're still talking yeah
we're still on the internet it was a
warning I mean it's like a fire broke
out in here right now that would be that
would be one of you guys drop dead of
course I like I told you before one of
you drops dead
I'm Audi 5000 if why don't you drive
said I'm going to Oak Island I'm gonna
tell you why cuz the theory is you can
skip the crow did you
I didn't skip the crab good don't forget
about the cool the crows gonna be a
letdown because there's not much about
the bedlam of the crow is the teaser at
the top so the theory is is that the
only way that treasure is gonna be found
in Oak Island is once all of two things
two variables all of the oak trees are
gone and all of them are gone and the
second variable is seven people must die
so because six is an incomplete nothing
completed sixes can ever be the end you
guys right get to seven that's right so
we're one death away from finding that
treasure okay now we may as well get
into the other theories because we're
up to about present day I mentioned the
brothers their names are mark and ready
ready mark and Marty and Rick and Rick
lagina now if you either name but
they're selling tickets to this place
well can go and you can visit no they
they're gonna one-up you on this that
you can but they have a show on the
History Channel
about this place they have a whole show
have a whole show oh gosh don't give
four seasons of a show
hunting for this treasure it's call I
think it's called the curse of Oak
Island I believe is I've seen some of it
and haven't seen all of it oh they're
brothers they never intended to be
reality got four seasons so going it's
still going and apparently people are
hooked someone out there who Morgan was
telling me that his dad or his wife's
dad or something every time he talks to
him is always say hey do you see see the
cursed the mystery of the cursed Island
but isn't whatever the heck it's called
like following yeah he's following but
it's but it's it's these two brothers
who are like it's them dealing with
owning this thing kind of thing reality
show about those reality show about them
their crew some other people treasure
hunters who are digging down finding
clues and they're determined to bring up
the treasure so they're the most recent
team of people and they gave them a
shell okay and so again it's like just
like you said the money pit the fact
that this thing exists is generating
income for these guys yes now it is
probably two million pounds when your
that's right apparently I read the
number as high as ten million was put
into over the years of trying to find
this treasure it could be between two
and ten it was probably more likely on
the higher end because a lot of these
people put a lot of money into this but
yeah these guys are making money now off
of this so what is the status of what
technology they're using like eventually
you see you said something about an iron
plate at some point right so how far are
they down as it still filled with water
have they have they completely plugged
the flooding part yeah some stage they
were they were able to I think what they
did was blow up those tunnels they would
be some dynamite or something
I'll fill them in ya collapsed him in
and they were able to extract the water
and keep digging they got past that iron
plate I'm not sure that how far they've
gotten I think this map here is outdated
because I think this one goes down at
212 feet okay so they're through the
water table yes point there through that
plate there through the water table
there and I guess there's even some
water
deep down buried beneath it but they've
gotten far through it no actual treasure
chest has come up they still believe
that something is down there because who
would go to all these great lengths to
do this unless it's an elaborate prank
but they've got they've gotten below
where the where the headstone that the
guy put in his fireplace said right it
was gonna be and they found there was an
oak chest with parchment just below 150
feet you know so it seems like but it
was empty
right well what they think there's a lot
of high rank yeah could be a pirate
break but there's a lot of theories I'm
gonna go through some of the theories
with you guys to see if any of them
stick okay and again these are all
theories so one of them is that
well besides what's in there I told you
about the deaths and I told you about
the oak trees another guy said that on
the History Channel that a pack of wild
dogs with those fiery eyes has been seen
on the island and they protect the pit
also a believe that part a crow who who
embodies a spirit of some ancient figure
watches over the pit I'm John Wayne
maybe I told you is a bit of a letdown
me to get your hopes up about that crap
there's a John Wayne news because escrow
possess Crow and rabid dogs dog yes John
Wayne was founded like 40 pounds of
impacted fecal matter in his died yes
what I heard on one of those I heard
that I'm like one of those late-night
infomercials for some fiber product
they're like you know that John Wayne
was found with 40 pounds of impacted
fecal matter in this body it later
turned into a crow that I don't his
family's getting a piece of that that
guards I mean the money not the paper
okay so but that's dope you can't you
can't make claims like that and not to
sell a product not pay John Wayne's
estate yeah I got a have a John Wayne on
it we got a piece of that yeah his
estate yeah I like John Wayne too
so then let's get to the theories about
the treasure there's one of the the most
common theory I think of the Canadians
and the Islanders up there is that it's
buried pirate treasure
specifically Captain Kidd Captain Kidd's
Maddy with two DS I don't really know
much about Captain Kidd there's a good
hole digger yeah he's a good old if it
is I mean yeah buried treasure
there's a reason why you associate yeah
but there's a buried treasure knows like
buried treasure but they didn't bury
this deep on the way on the Reg because
you don't have to what what you mind of
area that is very special but seriously
what I'm trying to wrap my mind around
is maybe I'm wrong about assuming how
difficult it would be to do this because
let me just start by saying they did dig
wells I mean they dug wells thousands of
years ago so people can dig let's just
start with the fact people can dig and
the 1700s 1600s whatever people were
capable of digging and if you could dig
oh well all the way down to this area
which if this was a well at some point
right somebody right then they were like
hey let's fill in that well I got an
idea I got an idea that's rets theory
yeah let's fill the well in but as we go
we'll do some crazy stuff and put in it
hey throw in Earl's hand I know what
came off is it still still out yeah
throw it in there let's just confuse the
crap out of some people put some weird
stuff in there just for funsies because
a lot of it's a lot booby-trapped oh no
just let me just finish my theory so
that makes sense in terms of what you
would never dig down to do this but if
you already dug down dug down for water
purposes right you might you may do go
through all this effort for funsies just
going up but you're right the one big
hull actually five big holes in my
theories are the five tunnels that come
in from the side because that my friends
is very difficult to do
in that kind of sandy soil that you
would think was very difficult to
buttress is the correct word yes you
know what I'm saying those side tunnels
I know okay that's the tricky part
there might be an explanation for it in
one guys theory which is that and this
is one of the more creative ones you
ever heard the idea that Shakespeare
didn't write his plays yeah and he
wasn't a person yeah or that he was not
smart enough to write them and you just
put his name on it
yeah and Sir Francis Bacon wrote the
plays didn't know about that that's one
of the theories so there's this
professor I think her name is dr. Ruth
from I always take University okay I
know she knows about and she says that
knows about different holes different
Ruth different holes yeah that might not
even be her name I think it is she says
that that VI that I brought up earlier
yeah that was that sheepskin parchment
she said I bet there's mercury down
there too when she heard that that was
dug up and the reason why was because
apparently mercury was used to preserve
things and I guess they did find mercury
all over that island and she said that
she knew that because Sir Francis Bacon
wrote a lot back in that time about Hall
he used mercury to preserve things so
what she believed
Jumping those conclusions was that all
the manuscripts that Sir Francis Bacon
wrote is what's buried down there to
prove that he's actually the real
Shakespeare in Nova Scotia in Nova
Scotia sir bacon and apparently he was
like the best scientist of the time so
that she was like well of course he
could devise all these tunnels and all
these crazy contraptions he's smart and
the only external clues are that
triangle that's out in the ocean the
trap there was other little ones too
that they found along the way but the
question is are they always there right
put him there right because there's
right if that theory is true right then
he wanted this to be found right and you
got to go you got to go deeper than just
a sunken depression on a weird
the coast of Canada you got a in other
words I think that there would be
evidence in his in his writings right
that later
so people looked into that um maybe
obviously or the answer that question or
not yeah yeah you're not working for the
History Channel you're working with the
clergy exactly what I mean what's there
what are the other theories and what's
what's your pick uh I got a theory what
I like a lot is that the this was
constructed by the Knights Templar the
Knights Templar were like in like I
don't like Illuminati kinda yeah but
back in the day when they first started
they were like a military religious
thing that eventually turned into kind
of what the Freemasons are today but
there's a lot of history about them with
treasure and the Holy Grail and they
buried treasure and they were known to
be frequent these parts and so one of
the theories here said that the Knights
Templar had been linked to the mystery
of Oak Island by many primarily because
historical records suggest that they had
both motive and means to deposit
treasure in the money pit and this is
their connection with the Holy Land
prompting speculation of untold wealth
in the form of the Holy Grail so people
think the Holy Grail is down there
probably not again I mean I I think that
someone started digging a hole and then
they just started is it was just let's
perpetuate this prank
I think people came in iteratively in in
trying to find treasure and dug further
and then when they didn't find anything
they perpetuated the myth to keep to
make it a money pit forever other people
to try to find something that wasn't
there but who put the stuff there to
begin with so there wasn't there was
like a little shallow something over
time people physically think about what
you're suggesting you're thinking it was
something like a jug and they fill it
back in and somebody dug a little bit
further then fill it back you know
everyone the worst thing I've ever heard
know when you get listen the History
Channel let's start there they got four
seasons out of this thing right what
what they don't want to find people
didn't know about the robbery Channel
I'm saying I'm you saying
retha you see the History Channel people
went back in time now I believe that
History Channel was like listen we're
struggling alright I gotta send somebody
back that I built with my iterative
theory dig a big hole because that
doesn't make any sense one thing this
was a one-time thing people now don't
want to find treasure they want to they
want to have more seasons of a
television show and make money and the
only way they believe they actually can
which is not finding anything but making
everyone else think the History Channel
gonna find the History Channel has the
treasure they might have if the treasure
exists they found a History Channel not
covering it up without it yeah by night
I mean it's 200 feet deep right it's a
it's a it's separate you know it's what
ten feet wide whatever I mean at this
point guys you don't have to meet me and
you could go down there and a couple of
speedos and start moving around and find
something you don't think it's like send
us down there for a couple of weeks
we'll come back with something I don't
wanna wear a speedo I get all scuffed up
first it's you know wear a romper a
romper is like a wetsuit romper man I
can legitimize history a little bit
though do it I will
and a couple quick ones it's a coffin is
another theory some some one guy said he
thinks it's just a sinkhole but I mean
he's coughing like a burials yeah like a
berry yeah like it was a yeah
tomb the brothers and this is kind of
the last thing I had here for you guys
the guys that host this show for season
strong I guess it's more popular than
ever now they're on Colbert earlier in
the year I believe they I saw an article
they said they're gonna get that
treasure but if you want to figure out
what it is you gotta tune in to season
five yeah so link might be on to
something here man oh no why would they
find it a complete I completely believe
that they know exactly found the
treasure before they bought the land
they but they found the treasure they
were like they got this idea they taught
the History Channel they're like reality
TV especially 2006 is where reality TV
was the future oh yeah what the writers
strike was was around that time the
first writers strike right or one of the
writers strikes 2007 and doesn't time
out exactly but you know what I mean if
it wasn't for those booby trap tunnels
which I think what I was trying to say
what
were dug later in order to legitimize a
continued search that's feasible yes
what I was trying to say that's
definitely because that's the only thing
we really got to explain is these
tunnels like someone someone digging a
hole and then what we really need is
somebody with a civil engineering civil
engineering degree to like contemplate
this yeah I don't know anybody and some
khakis yeah man I mean I haven't I can't
say that I'm gonna watch the show I feel
like I got it I got I got my money's
worth in this beer biscuit yeah that's
what we do for the people it's like we
sum up seasons of reality TV and all of
the all the commercials you gotta in do
I think all I'd like the teasers before
there's a lot of people are gonna go
watch that show now these guys should be
thanking us thank you we welcome
brothers you know what we invite the
brothers on our show yeah let's get you
brothers on yeah come on our show what I
will say is that what this inspires me
to do is I think that we should set our
sights on a wolf on a late-in-life
project similar to this I love I love do
you know we're gonna get we're gonna be
so bored with everything man let's just
make a pact right now if we make it to
if we're still alive at 75 which
hopefully we will be it's not too old
right that's the whole dig in prime no
no no no we'll hire some young young
young guys some young bucks put them in
speed hose won't be like that
Robbins put them all in rompers let us
Rob them and have them do it but it'll
be our brain children and we'll leave a
legacy man that'll be our legacy that'll
be the legacy thing we live is a big old
hole we'll go 400 feet deep think of the
technology think of all the things we
can we'll put crows inside cages along
the way I can talk you can teach them to
talk and give them little fly tunnels
from the side I and you know what it was
a good way towards setting it up right
now it will be a reality television show
but it'll be a reality competition show
because we're gonna you booby-trapped
that stuff what's that like Indiana
Jones man I'm talking boulders rolling
out like
people do people go and die we're gonna
die if they're gonna sign a waiver first
and we're gonna film it on we're gonna
set up rows we're gonna set up cameras
as we go now where we should put the
wiring in it'll all be wireless here's
the one just a couple of requests at
this point I want it to be like it was
I don't want it to be a straight hole I
want it to be like a crazy straw you
know we're gonna go down we're gonna
back up sideways currently we're
building obstacle course treasure hunt
things it's life or death situation I'm
on the same world and we're creating
seasons and seasons of shows for spike
okay whatever it'll be that point but we
cannot tell people where these are gonna
be I can safely say there won't be any
in Nova Scotia I'm not interested
they've already dug a hole yeah can use
that so always been no no production
value no that's just the beginning of
one of our holes man our holes it's so
much bigger you can be like one of the
Probst oh really
yeah you can host the show yeah you'll
be old man dang he's legitimately like
one of my favorite hosts on television
yeah well he's not available you can I
go I got real excited when you said you
could be jet pro yeah I got way more
excited than I should yes I mean you
have to drag out the dead bodies but
it'll be awesome and in the least if we
don't do that grand plan we should at
least like hide like a USB Drive in some
city somewhere that's more real is this
teasers paid off man I might have to go
to Nova Scotia
yeah well go during the summer cold down
in a hole
[Music]
and there you have it our intriguing
biscuit with Kevin Kevin mythical crew
Kevin did he did a good job
he brought the intrigue he's not deep he
started with some teasers then he he dug
deep for that yes he did yeah yeah it's
very I don't know this is the kind of
thing I'm gonna be thinking about how
many thinking about when I go to bed
tonight I'm gonna be thinking about that
that whole it is wondering what's out
there right now III enjoyed the
conversation but you know anything about
it I'm gonna tuck it away and I'm just
gonna I think about the back of my
eyelids when I go to sleep I just don't
dawn out and just like we laugh well you
live leave the thinking to me that's
cool Wow while you're sleeping I don't
need you to think for me while I'm sleep
all right if you got any thoughts that
you want to send our way let us know
using hashtag ear biscuits wherever
hashtags are found because we value the
conversation we value your feedback also
reviews on iTunes are extremely helpful
so give us that review yeah and if you
found this conversation intriguing and
interesting you are going to like the
book of mythicality again available for
pre-order at book of mythicality calm
this kind of these kinds of tidbits that
spark your curiosity it's the book full
of them personal stuff and stuff that we
just find personally interesting so book
of mythicality calm get it while it gets
good and we'll be speaking at you next
week mythical beasts love you I wanted
to say love you well I think we cut
before that we actually didn't know okay
love you
[Music]